it's feels like we've been gone for a
long time it's really this this felt
like a long break and it's a little over
a week I mean oh is it just a week in a
day basically yeah pretty much that's
all it is and it's not like we've been
gone but I went to Iceland for the the
time period and something happens when
you're away when you're not working like
at one point I was like six days into
the trip and I'm like I feel like I've
been here for a [ __ ] month right like
you start remembering things you did the
first day you know like that was only
five days ago like because it's almost
like like after three days you're you
start adjusting like it's almost a
lifestyle change right it's not just
this quick in-and-out vacation like six
days in you're like this is what I do no
I hang out in Iceland I just know the
hotel like this is my life now I'm not
good at being away in one place for a
long time I'm not I'm not good at doing
that I'm glad I did it I enjoyed it I
actually wound up staying for those
extra two days really I stayed longer
than I was supposed to how long you stay
in Iceland for oh I I'm the eighth day I
came back I stayed for over a week
why unheard of for me yeah I'm all in
the same place not jumping around
we went well I went Friday after the
show that we finished the show I got
picked up immediately went and then I
was supposed to come back the following
Thursday morning but I wanted to stay
until the following Saturday morning Wow
your pictures in video from vacation
were awesome thank you penis Museum that
captured it wasn't by I had a specially
made seat a long time in the souvenir
shop did you and I I really did there's
a bunch of stuff that may or may not be
given away next Monday night it was a
really really fun trip so you there's a
there's a penis museum in Iceland it's
called the phallological Museum
phallological Museum and it was
something we did like oh really
that really changes the the perspective
of sleeve song la la la ya la la la la
logical yeah it really did I had heard
about it and like you started running
out of stuff to do in a small country
it's not a huge country there's only 340
thousand people living there now when
there's
dick museum you never run out of fun how
can you not go to that I didn't go to a
glacier I didn't go to a volcano we did
do this we did go to I did a whole bunch
of stuff I just liked it like because I
wasn't we texted back and forth here and
there but like I didn't know what you
were doing on your vacation cuz I
figured you know find out when you get
back but so my dad or whoever would ask
me like Oh what's Jim doing over there
and I go I don't know he's gonna dick
Museum cuz I just thought your Twitter
too
so that's the only thing though that you
put on Twitter that and your Northern
Lights tour which I'll talk about in a
second but but you were you you did a
photo like you did a ton you don't take
vacation photos real no and you just
posted a ton of voters from the dick
museum well there wasn't many things to
see like the first you know again the
first night you're there I got in late
so it was just basically get settled in
and then the second day was there I had
was the McGregor fight that was the
Saturday night so it was a matter of
when I had to do is I had to find a
place that was going to show the Conor
McGregor Floyd Mayweather fight I didn't
think I'd be able to get it on my UFC
fight pass and we'll talk about the
fight of course but one of one of the
greatest texts I'd ever gotten followed
by the greatest disappointments ever was
during the day on Saturday the day of
the fight remember we've been given Jim
a hard time for going to Iceland instead
of watching it here with you guys right
because we were like you could throw a
party at your place and we could all
come over just mooching off of Jim but
he goes to Iceland you know right after
the show instead
and so Jim texted me on Saturday and
he's like hey are you ordering the fight
and I said yeah and then he goes I'm
having trouble with my fight pass and I
don't know if I'll find a place that is
good to watch the fight would it be okay
maybe if I Skyped you and then you
pointed your computer to the fight
psycho
please let this happen that's what I
thought I would you and Bob Kelly
because I'm like if one of these guys
doesn't watch the fight I have to have
two options but I thought that's what I
might have to do I couldn't find
anywhere that was showing it yeah
and there was a bar called the Big
Lebowski which was or Lebowski's it was
one of them it was right across the
street from where we were staying and I
heard they were showing the fight but we
had walked by it on the Friday night
when I got there and it was a [ __ ]
madhouse what time what's the time
difference over there I I think it's
four hours which meant that the fight
was gonna be starting at about 2:00 in
the morning all right
Floyd and and Connor so I'm like by two
o'clock in the morning in Iceland the
way they drink over there and they are a
nation of [ __ ] alkies drunks yeah
there's nothing to do there in the West
sure until they drink and I mean you
know it's summer now it's still--it's
they get used to very being indoors and
drinking so I was like [ __ ] man
and I'm UFC fight pants I thought was
gonna be showing it but I'm like I
wasn't able to it wasn't able to say
that I could watch it so I'm like maybe
because I'm in Iceland there's a problem
it turns out that defy pass did work but
they only turned it on like a half-hour
before that was just oh I see so Sam was
willing to uh would have loved to do it
and we wound up going over there at
there would have been some glitches
right before the fight just to watch you
I'm a meltdown handing a little bit yeah
here we went over there like 9:00 p.m.
and we went up getting the front table
the best seat in the house 9:00 p.m.
uh no no no maybe 1:00 p.m. so I 1 p.m.
I which is 9 p.m. this time oh no wait
no no what time did you go Iceland time
I'm trying to think I went a little
after 12:00 ok so you're only talking a
couple hours before the five hours five
hours before the hell I not being there
for five hours if I told ya I didn't
start till about 5:00 a.m. I saw all the
the prelims it was just the undercard
that is a couple of good fights I mean I
didn't care about them but there were a
couple of good fights but you we had to
get that we get the front table but I
couldn't leave here closest to the
screen was it because you were there so
early no those people that were yeah
that was that was one of the main
reasons but even by the end it was there
was not that many people there so I
think it was raining in Iceland so the
fact that it rained kept people away I
think people just had [ __ ] it and stayed
home but so what day did you go to dick
museum I think that's the most important
that was which days why spent that's why
you spent the eighth day
nice thing because you realize I just
spent a week at the dick Museum I get
like I know that when I go to Disney
World you can get multi-day passes right
you probably do that at the dick Museum
right like you're not going to the Magic
Kingdom one day like you'd like to
explore a second day because the first
day it's sensory overload and you're
doing all these fun things and the
second day you go back because you
missed some stuff and then the third day
you go back to find the Hidden Mickeys
like oh I didn't notice that Finas right
so like Jim was going back on the third
day to find all the hidden testicles all
over the plant look one of the best
things I did before I went to the dick
Museum and this is courtesy of Bill burr
who told me he said Bill technically
would tell me he sent me a picture of
this place called Blue Lagoon
I thought he sent you a picture that you
could use as an exhibit in the day no no
red pubes he sent me a photo this place
called the Blue Lagoon spa which is like
one of those natural hot spring spas
mm-hmm [ __ ] we wound up going for
just one night because there was a hotel
that was sold out so we hit we can only
get one night in the hotel and the Blue
Lagoon is just like this natural Hot
Springs spa gigantic it was gigantic
it's like a lake of just hot water and
there's people that walk around man-made
or is it real it's man maybe the water
in it is legit like I think they
actually just built they carved out a
place for the water to flow to and you
go in there and it's uh it's a weird
what's it really like it's filled with
minerals and stuff like you keeps hard
to even keep yourself underwater like
when you sink underwater you pop back up
it's like being in like a what's the
Dead Sea I'm think gotcha
it's probably called salt and mineral
pee in it multiple times multiple times
there's people that walk around with
these weird masks you can put on your
face uh-huh like the one mass they walk
around so everybody's walking around
like a bunch of [ __ ] zombies because
you have this weird like these clay
masks you can put on your face which are
like exfoliator and the one of them is
white and one of them is blue so you're
walking around there's hundreds if you
wear one multiple ones you walk up
foliated while you were there I rubbed
it all over my face I'm just walking
around
because my my lady friend was getting a
massage I see there's only one must want
massage available so I let her get it so
while your lady friend is getting a
massage she decided to pamper yourself a
little bit with some with an exfoliation
mask in the pissing lake and that yes
and that that Lake you're looking at or
that's the one from the hotel that's the
private Lagoon the first one was was the
public one which it was hundreds of
people in it and I thought it was gonna
suck because I'm like oh there's all
these [ __ ] people and everybody there
was nice like what an amazing experience
everybody was friendly and happy nobody
had shitty attitude me included like
normally I have a shitty attitude and I
can't just blame the public I'm not part
of the problem but I wound up going in
this thing and just I felt amazing they
were influenced in a positive way by the
environment yeah and the waters they got
in between 92 and 104 degrees Jesus but
it's so there's so much room to expand
and walk out and be by yourself like
look at all that area you have it looks
like it's claustrophobic but it's really
not like you could be by yourself oh so
when you say there's like I mean it's
been having 100 people you know whatever
but it looks like it's like over an acre
of what gigantic yeah there's plenty of
little places to go and to duck into
there's like a sauna and a steam room is
there a place where you can do
cannonballs you know I don't think you
were allowed to jump in oh but it was it
was uh the the I had what are they
called the the lifeguards have [ __ ]
these they're like dressed like in
winter gear because it was getting a
little chilly that was like in the 40s
and the 50s oh really
yeah it wasn't like here oh so you jump
into like the hot water but it's cold
outside it was a maze I can't want to go
back in the winter I want to go back in
the winter because it must be amazing
when it's freezing out yeah to be in
hundred degree water and then the hotel
you have your own private Lagoon
and where there's like 40 on the private
Lagoon in the hotel my god did you see
pee in it yeah no I did I do you see the
master people were wearing there were
these white masks but it feels good to
rub on your face it does yeah is that
rough exfoliation rough exfoliation and
the one that was blue was like an algae
mask did you put that one on - yes I did
oh my god I couldn't find any blue algae
and I finally saw a lady walking around
they walked around these bowls
with these [ __ ] scoopers in it have
you have you seen the blue algae lady
have you is it was the blue algae lady
did she pass by here already and I saw
that she came over and she gave me some
oh good and I got a second helping oh
you did yeah you know seconds yes I did
seconds oh my gosh but there's a really
pampered yourself it was just a weird
like normal person vacation and the
hotel the problems are annoyed enjoy tea
if you ask me yeah it was but I never do
I've never died I've never you don't go
on vacation no I don't I don't do this
type of stuff in my life so I never feel
guilty when I do it cuz yeah I just
don't do it yeah and I'm happy I did it
and I can't wait to [ __ ] do it again
you didn't do gigs no I did no gigs I
started began at the end of this month I
was happy to I was like [ __ ] just but
that that was so relaxing the hotel is
boring though because it shuts down
everything closes like the hotel shut
down it was like this is 45 minutes from
Reykjavik and it shut down it like
[ __ ] you know 11 o'clock and then by
then the restaurants closed so it's a
peaceful night so I would bring a few
snack to the next time because there's
not much it died to eat there and this
little silly couple snacks I'll promote
the silica hotel one of the best things
I've ever done but bring some snacks
bring some snacks
I see dude it's weird you walk into it
you want to go out into the private
lagoon and you walked into like a locker
room area I mean you walk out of the
locker rooms into this enclosed warm
bath area inside you put your stuff you
take your stuff off and then you get
into the warm bath and there's a door in
the water that you pull open in the
water and then you walk right out and
you're in the private Lagoon so you
don't need that that's how they stopped
you from having to walk out and like the
cold yes and I didn't know that
hypothermia I didn't know that yeah I
walked outside with my [ __ ] I was
freezing and then she just walked out
I'm like what a dope I am through the
wrong door yeah said I just got in the
bath inside and the way it's weird to
see a door it was like being a flood
because there's a door halfway flooded
and you pull it open and you just walk
and you're like you float into this
amazing where the good-looking people
because that picture that Troy just some
hot chick in a little string bikini
hanging out in the lagoon with a dumb
face mask on there was every single
imaginable body type and
a shape in the main one and the private
one there's only like five or six people
and you're walking in the private one
and what got weird is the ground was
really slimy it was like stepping in
[ __ ] algae and a fish tank in the
private ones yeah and I got really
skeeved out I'm like they don't wash
these [ __ ] floors and then I'm like
what is this [ __ ] because there's white
sediment all around the rocks there's
all this emit this weird white hardened
it looks fake it looks like they have
put porcelain around the entire thing
all this and she thought it was face
like they painted this but I'm like no
there's too much of it and it goes up
the rocks and too much of a weird non
patterned way I'm like this is all the
minerals that just dry so there was it
was just like algae or something on the
ground we scooped it up you scoop it up
it was this white stuff it was like soft
white clay and then it stopped grossing
me out once I realized it was the same
[ __ ] that I was throwing on my face oh
there's the door that's the door that
you walk at a water door and it smelled
like farts so I felt really at home
which to wear where a lot of water did
cuz it was no that was sulfur in the
water which is really good for you yeah
I know but it stinks I don't care so
does I always smell like that so I felt
like I was home right and they're like
oh who farted and you're like I'm not
telling I think it's just the Psalter
word I was in Paradise - I farted all
over Iceland the volcano yeah it's not
me I swear dude I [ __ ] did your
ladyfriend enjoy watching you getting
pampered you know it was weird she
didn't uh yeah I mean she was she I
didn't wanna get pampered I just meant
you were to face masks and you know
walking around in an algae pool but she
was doing it - yes two seconds yeah you
got seconds on your algae I think that
while she was getting a massage she
didn't know you got seconds no but it
was just fun we just had fun I haven't
never done that like just God never had
fun I've had great life but I mean I've
just never done like a vacation like
that right it's been many many years
since has done part water and a penis me
just trying to piece together what a
normal vacation could be like yeah like
well I
not being like III I'm not being a pig
so this must be what a normal vacation
is like yeah I was always a very good
boy so okay so you spend time in the
fart pool and you piss all over it I did
piss a lot I tinkled in the water so and
then you go to the dick museum after you
got pampered no but that was a few days
later we weren't going to see the North
oh we did that but I think the Digby say
before the Northern Lights did somebody
say like oh there's this [ __ ] Museum
that you got to see we heard about it
I'd you know I thought it'd be funny to
go to like what did the concierge would
be like well we have this pool where you
can get algae masks in the pool and it's
actually really nice we have a giant
[ __ ] and balls Museum and a couple of
restaurants well I wanna I wanted to
want to feel my hands are soft my hand
is mmm if I exfoliate it didn't think my
skin feels so soft
did you bring home any ex any Iceland
exfoliant no do you think you're gonna
change your beauty regiment now no oh my
beauty regimen is very good it is easier
obviously I mean you wouldn't you should
just feel it back in my hand though
feels smooth it is Troy why don't you
feel it yeah yeah it's awesome
exfoliation yeah feel Jim's hands just
smooth it is baby smooth Wow is that
from the exfoliant is yeah I my own
comfortably over the back of it no we uh
yeah after a while you get a little bit
bored oh one thing I did I want to do I
went to the Bobby Fisher Museum there's
a Bobby Fisher museum to gets where he
died he died in in Iceland so I wound up
going to his uh the the Bobby Fisher was
it next door to the penis Museum
no it's far away we I rented a car and I
drove to the Bobby Fisher they drive on
the right side of the road no big the
one we do they drive on our side of the
road so that's what scared me and I want
to go going there and uh they drive the
same as a scarab be the idea that they
might not gotcha and then I wanted to go
in and do that and I went to his grave I
always kind of wanted to go to his grave
and it was it was you know it wasn't
itself so it sounds when I put on a
solemn video I don't what didn't feel
that solemn I was like you don't want to
be a [ __ ] maniac while you're at
somebody's grave but it didn't feel like
alright let's watch it it's only 50
seconds
so one thing I had wanted to do when I
was in Iceland is I wanted to go to
bobby fischer's grave so we went to the
Bobby Fischer center and it was nice
little knickknacks from the match in
Reykjavik and this is this is where he's
Burt it's uh this church behind me catch
you iceland tour guide you yeah they're
doing some construction here where's the
grave I show I'm just showing the area
to see it's just like a regular tiny
Church but it's just a little quiet
place I expected to be a big crowd of
people I'm like spying me mobbed and
here it is yeah that's it it's a little
tiny headstone I did expect it to be a
big crowd though yeah so I'm glad I came
or at least like some kind of people
like some kind of tour nobody nobody was
there but us so I don't know why I
thought was gonna be a mob like all God
is give me a bus tour bus in front of us
oh yeah ours chest is the hottest thing
in the world right now yeah that when
you say like that that is a good point
yeah Plus that hot movie searching for
Bobby Fischer's don't just tear up
tearing up movie theaters across the
colors
yeah probably my overestimating yeah the
public demand to go and see the grave of
a guy who did nothing but rail about
9/11 in juice I thought there'd be a hot
spot for young people I see it as the
same thing as Graceland no Graceland is
popular oh is it a madhouse oh I wonder
why Elvis is more popular than Bobby if
it really is huh but I was happy I went
though there was I tried to buy
something from the museum I knew they
wouldn't sell it what kind of
knickknacks did they have I know what to
say yeah you tried to buy some of the
knickknacks they had done try to do it
in every Museum he's like our Linux for
sale
how much for Jeff I'll leave what if I
leave all the chess pieces here but how
much for just the board they I tried to
buy I asked about though these a lot of
the stuff was for sale I was a a
bookstore it was like a Bobby Fischer
Center and they have a few things
because it most of the stuff from the
copies of mine Kampf no they didn't have
that Oh assigned by Bobby yeah they do
they kind of just focus on the chest
part
they did act out the whole anti-jew
thing a stay on the Jews a but I live it
was just pictures of his life and and
things it was one chair i sat in which
was Bobby's she was actually a chair he
had sat it in this bookstore wreck you
back that he loved and actually did sit
in that I was happy to sit in a chair
that Bobby had sat in Bobby Fischer said
I really did think that way yeah I was
very it was one of my longest standing
favorite people but I wanted to the
board and all that stuff they said in
the National Museum like none of the
real stuff is there so what were you
trying to buy they have tickets to the
match and they had stuff like whenever
you play a chess match you would that
you annotate them out you you write all
these you write your moves down sure and
there was the carbon through like the
original ones in the museum but there
was a carbon under it and the carbon was
in the Bobby Fischer Center so you try
to buy the car no no no I was only
nobody got there but there are some
tickets to the original match that were
stamped yeah and it was like 20 of them
but don't let you guys sell these like
know how much you want I would have
given him I would have I would have paid
a lot for him how much would you pay for
I don't know but I have nothing and
bobby fischer's i would love to have
something i would love to have something
that was his but it's impossible to get
i just loved the idea of jim going
through like the Bobby Fischer museum
and going how much for that it's not for
sale okay and then go to something else
what about this how much for this is
asking you to buy every exhibit I did
watches this I did buy a shirt it was
not a great shirt a tee shirt I bought a
t-shirt at the Bobby Fischer Center they
have t-shirts at the Bobby Fischer's
that is the real stuff now they have a
couple of things but again tickets they
don't even have actual stuff that you
couldn't because well they do have here
- they have it honestly sounds like a
garbage Bobby Fischer display no it was
Travis do you think it sounds like a
good Bobby Fischer display it doesn't
sound like a good use of an afternoon
[Laughter]
can you imagine a little kid like if Jim
had like a like a five year old with him
just like how upset he would be that his
dad made him go to the fake Bobby
Fischer museum no well the real stuff is
in them is in the actual National Museum
that's why you gotta go there no I think
I didn't care about that I would rather
have gone like Bobby Fischer Center
Bobby Fischer sat in his chair once and
this is a copy of a thing that he wrote
and these are some tickets that other
people had to
it's you know it also had no it's none
of that stuff
it had I'll take they had triples of a
t-shirt that says don't play checkers in
a chess world they had a table shows the
table that they had there the world
match the match between him and Boris
Spassky was played on this really nice
table and they both sign it God I and I
hate to interrupt you the spelling of
souvenir that I just saw was it bad I
mean it was insane he was snow off but
go on I my apartment that the table that
was in the that's the table that was in
the know that one didn't have this no
that's the table that was actually in
the Bobby Fischer Center some exacta
table they played the match on the table
they played the match on there was only
five of them made in the world and the
one they actually played the match on
was a different color and I was signed
by Bobby and Boris and no but it's one
of the five it's a fifth of something
that Bobby Fischer was a part of yeah
the real table is in the actual National
Museum you can't get near it it's one of
four replicas no I don't know why they
made five it's like in the movies when
you buy something at auction and it's
like one of one of six Dorothy costumes
right but only one was used in the movie
we don't know these are the five this
could have been using no you know it
wasn't like one has wrinkles and it's
faded as this one's pristine yeah so
they had that that's not cool my shirt
was uh you probably won't like my shirt
when I wear it run a gray shirt I didn't
care oh cool they both signed that chess
board from the Bobby Fischer Center no
that's not from I don't think so in the
center that you were at is that you know
what do they sign that maybe they did I
didn't see it I think I would have seen
it no I think you would have chess
museum oh okay so that's not where Jim
was no I was the power Fisher Center
they have nothing that Bobby Fischer
actually touched except a chair that I
stole I do recommend it highly I here's
what as I called why would you recommend
this is his thing I wound up going there
and I felt like okay I'm it's only open
for two hours a day
we can't possibly waste everybody's time
for more it's amazing it's open for two
hours a day and still no line to get in
it was only open for two hours a day was
it crowded no I'll do it there was a guy
in there it's offseason and I wound up
going and I called and I said look you
guys open until and they said we close
at 4:00 it was like it was only 90
minutes left and I said oh and like both
stay open for you they told me they'd
stay open was it when he was talking to
you was his voice echoing off the walls
because there was a sound he had
anything else to do is there a language
barrier their English isn't like them no
but they all speak English okay all of
them so I got there 30 minutes to spare
20 minutes disparaged about a 15 minute
to an hour drive and the guy was very
nice drove an hour yes to get here well
I asked him where the grave was I knew
the grave the grave I wanted to see I
knew that was close by and it was
probably out six minutes five minute
drive down the road I guess since it's
his actual grave yeah can't be that mad
at that but but this Bobby Fischer
centers well that was just the greatest
goal a terrible spot the goal was the
grave I wanted to go there and so I said
okay let me go to the Bobby Fischer
Center is there can't see in the Bobby
Fischer center
are there supporter maybe it's the Pro
KFC supports the club it's nice they
should that is nice that is what did
your lady friend think of the Bobby
Fischer Center she was fine with it like
you know she knew I really wanted to go
and she was he didn't care she was okay
with it she enjoyed being like just she
didn't have any agenda
she was very easygoing like whatever we
did we did she didn't go far so she
probably because you were so
enthusiastic about all this nonsense she
probably didn't realize what a waste of
everyone's time it was well if she sat
through the Floyd Mayweather fight with
me we went to go into the bar and spend
their hours in this bar she didn't she
didn't mind that so yeah but at least
you were actually watching the fight
yeah like this would be like if you went
to a bar to watch a white guy and a
black
I pretend to be Floyd Mayweather and
Conor McGregor and just reenact the
fight like was he tickets from the fight
yeah this has no connection to Bobby the
Bobby Fischer Center is not connected to
Bobby Fischer at all sure it is it's his
center why don't they have any of his
stuff they have one think he get they
just have replicas well you know it's
hard because his stuff doesn't exist
there's not much of his stuff it exists
in the chest Museum the museum's get it
a museum is different than the center I
think there should have been a little
more stuff but his chair was there what
did the what did the shirt say but you
still even though you were like there
should probably be a little bit more in
the way of knickknacks because I heard
in the video that there were knickknacks
look few but not that many you know a
lot of pictures of Bobby I like that
they they were they had the audacity to
print shirts up for their Bobby Fischer
Center even though they had nothing of
note on display well it's just bass no
wasn't but it was basically just a shirt
it was a quote of his and I and I liked
it but this could be very inappropriate
for the workplace no no not a quote from
his later no no no no it's a quote about
chess what is the quote I checked out
the Bobby Fischer was there he says I
don't believe in psychology I believe in
good moves sure you wear that on your
next special oh you have to why would
you buy that shirt no it doesn't have
his face on it that one it just says the
quote I don't believe in psychology I
believe in good well someone asked them
about he just he was he was responding
to a question you're not trying to be
deep somebody's about the psychology of
it he said I don't believe in psychology
I believe in good move and then some
[ __ ] made it into a t-shirt and then
some bigger [ __ ] yes sir
there's the only one they had though oh
we had one and you would need a keepsake
for that I had that great for that great
trip are you gonna wear it
[ __ ] yeah but I bought a small though so
you know I packed on a couple over there
I ate a lot of desserts little
motivation oh I got to lose the weight
so I can wear my cool Bobby Fischer
t-shirt were you worried they wouldn't
have any
shirts left yes I was I was worried they
wouldn't have my size Oh what if they're
sold out yeah they weren't no they
weren't no there's plenty to go around
to wait on a long line no the merch team
out there was no mercy table I just
think I have this shirt you went yeah I
bought a book about the psychology the
psychological profile of Bobby Fischer
yeah but the book was all secondhand
assumptions because nobody associated
with the Bobby Fischer Center had any
connection to Bobby Fischer no that's
not true I know something that was
signed it's just a bunch of people that
went to one of his chess matches so
that's where they have all tickets no I
did buy a little thing that was
autographed so I was happy to get that
it's fake autograph no it was a real
autograph I hope it was a fake autograph
no it's one it's a stamp right yeah no
no what are you signing with marker or
pen well he didn't sign it was a sign no
no no it was signed by some Icelandic
chess master the guy who made the actual
Reykjavik match take place the guy who
well I did who's the only signature
available no these are the jewels this
is the guy who drove them to the match
[Laughter]
of the guy who put the match together
yeah so you have so this guy who talked
to Bobby Fischer yeah I did sign it was
it was this uh it might have been
something like this speech from Bobby's
wake or something like that it was like
your copy of it was a teeny little
five-page thing do you think he should
have spoken at Bobby's wake or the only
reason he spoke at Bobby's wake is
because Bobby was stuck in Iceland no
Bobby got citizenship he wanted to be
there it's where he wanted to go cuz the
US was gonna arrest him he arrested in
Japan that's what I mean if he hadn't
been arrested do you think he would earn
back in America and not allowing this
guy who you got his autograph no he left
America he wanted to leave America no I
think he would've been happy to be there
I don't know if any of these autographs
on eBay or legit I wouldn't pay for any
of them well see I wouldn't buy any of
them I've only seen one that I would pay
for what's the name of the guy who you
got his autograph
I don't remember the [ __ ] nose gives
a [ __ ]
you know fing danse Morris did you get
excited in the moment and buy a bunch of
stuff no I bought only hola how much you
pay for the autograph no the book was
that very cheap yeah 25 30 bucks not 40
bucks right but the book I bought was uh
it was like a good book on Bobby Fischer
I want to read it but he signed it no
there wasn't the other pamphlet I bought
how much how much yeah how much was the
pay am I having twenty bucks okay wasn't
some crazy you spend almost a hundred
dollars at the Bobby Fischer Center man
30 admission
well what yeah admission thousand kr
which is probably ten bucks I'd be
furious if somebody took my ten bucks
they I'm assuming they take your
admission obviously before you can go in
right yeah oh they just robbed people of
ten bucks no I didn't mind it though I
didn't mind spending the money admission
I am I to go and see nothing no it was
fun to go and see replicas of set to sit
in the chair that he used to read books
in the bookstore and ten bucks thousand
kr he said a thousand kr a thousand kr
is 125 dollars then it wasn't that I
just no no no no 100 oh it's not a
hundred bucks
Rhona maybe they are maybe 100 chrono a
thousand I think ten bucks it wasn't a
chess chair it was just a chair he sat
in in the bookstore to read his books in
I took a picture in the bin the chair he
used to read his books in the bookstore
probably rejected by a museum it was
just they had some of his okay what was
it they had the last five books that he
ordered at that bookstore but he never
got them because he died and one of them
was a book of dirty jokes but he never
touched the books no he died so he
didn't read them no he didn't so they
just had they just knew a guy who wore
to that bookstore but he just yeah
that's like saying we have Aziz Beatles
books right he never touched them that's
like you selling Aziz actually I
more time with the Beatle books and
Bobby did with no that's true yeah
that's right that's right oh my god that
was a great day what a colossal waste of
everyone that was a great day after that
was a that was our day I would be I
would be furious if they took my ten
dollars and I walked in there and I was
like oh my god I've been had this is
this is nothing more than carne
shenanigans I might as well be on the
boardwalk right now thinking that I'm
gonna be able to dunk a basketball in
that oval-shaped hoop they took my money
saw me coming
I'm surprised they didn't sell you a
bridge that was once owned by Bobby
Fischer I was happy to be there and look
at the paintings on the wall what kind
of paintings paintings and paintings of
Bobby of Bobby or by Bobby of him Bobby
paintings of Bobby it was a great day
any chess fan should go
I recommend any chess fan go they're not
his paintings though no they're not it's
just a guy painted a photo of Bobby and
they're like for $10 you can look at
them and then go to the grave I
recommend the grave can you go to the
grave without paying the 10 bucks you
can't sure what guy showed me where it
was it's hard to find it's in a back
area google map it I'm sure you can yeah
I I didn't mind spending the money what
a swindler this guy is no they had to
keep the lights on you know they don't
get a lot of is only two hours a day of
course they don't get a lot of visitors
I thought I'm surprised I thought it's
gonna be like a huge thing yeah nobody's
interested
it's a terrible exhibit no wasn't
terrible I should have brought flowers
to the grave I kind of wish I had for
wine just to do it why not I would have
teased you if you had done that
oh they exhumed him I forgot about that
to make sure somebody wasn't his oh oh
oh yeah someone was saying they were
related to him I wish I had been there I
would have taken like a hair it would
have been better than anything you got
that shitty I would think I would have
taken something off the corpse if that
museum was that creepy you would have
grave robbed Bobby Flay pull one of his
hairs out you would have turned yourself
into a grave robber because of your
fandom for bobby fisher' yeah they sure
they should have stolen some hair for
the goddamn museum I agree it would have
been much much better yeah this one girl
was saying that she was his daughter and
she wanted a piece the money that would
have been like going to
the dick museum and all they had were
scrotums there was a dick on this
scrotum once there was not a lot of
dicks there of human there's only a
couple there were a couple human dicks
though yeah it was mostly animal dicks
so it's really a weird place so this is
the other Museum you go to somebody
decides in Iceland like we need to
further examine penises yeah we need a
museum for that yep and you were like we
should go check that out because the
Bobby Fisher Museum was such a raging
success Instagram pulled my video my
pictures down from the penis museum
those babies why they really wanted
museums Awards real ly the worst I see
Eric Andre's penis on Instagram a
hundred times yeah they took it I think
they took them all down
that's ridiculous silly nobody probably
complained I mean if I was yawning in
front of one it was a silly photo
there's Jim was yawning in front of one
of the penises hanging off the wall so
what is the and saying this is not a
great place to yawn it was a very small
museum another one that's just like two
rooms of just dicks a lot of whale dicks
are huge well I would hope so yeah I
mean the bigger than you think like how
big are they let me see I'll find the
picture and the guy who runs the dick
museum it might be what a creep yeah he
was a what did I tweet a dick a whale
dick or no I don't think so I saw the
photo that you tweeted of of the
pictures I love that one of the two guys
yeah they were side by side one guy has
a giant dick and you can clearly see his
face and one guy has a little tiny dick
in his face is blurred yeah yeah but you
could still by the way completely see
his face through the blur down yeah it's
not doing an effective blurring job now
it's like they just kind of scratched up
the frame but you can still see the
guy's weird porn mustache